tu as lu aujourd'hui je suis avec gaël
gaël c'est pas n'importe qui c'est un
real mon gars tu avais tu réalises pas
encore ce qui va t'arriver
mais dans les studios de
notrefamille.com où je viens ici deux
jours par mois pour réaliser des vidéos
qui vont être diffusée bientôt je crois
dans quelques mois
les gens profitent comme aujourd'hui on
est mardi pour faire la vidéo qui sort
ce mardi parce que je suis un petit peu
à la mort j'ai lu récemment qu'il y
avait un garçon un jeune garçon qui
avait aidé la nasa a trouvé la dernière
cité des mayas il s'est rendu compte que
dans les étoiles si on les raccorder
ensemble ça faisait le tracé des cités
mayas et qui a une étoile qui était qui
couvrait pas qui avait pas de site et
donc il aura dit allez fouiller la balle
et ils sont allés fouiller donc je vois
ça magnifique que je te demande et gaël
c'est d'imaginer que tu es en train de
découvrir une étoile c'est à toi c'est
ton étoile à toi c'est la tienne
personnel et comme c'est toi qui l'a
découverte
c'est pas une cité de m la découverte
est une étoile tu vas pouvoir lui donner
un nom n'importe quel nom faut pas me le
dire
évidemment ça peut être n'importe quoi
ça peut être un nom d'animal mais ça
peut être aussi à un objet du quotidien
ça peut être ce que tu veux toi d'accord
tu me dit pas lequel tu en as en tête et
en attendant peut-être regarde-moi temps
à en tête qui devient c'est sûr ouais
c'est sûr ok du quotidien moi je vais
pas trop regarder je vais pas essayer de
deviner quoi que ce soit j'ai juste
marquer comment moi j'appellerai mon
étoile si j'en trouvais il se soit fait
plus ou moins une
une prédiction je sais quoi moi moi
voilà comment je l'appellerai assez bien
c'est gentil de pas regarder je vais
leur faire voir ce que je suis en train
d'écrire moi voici comment j'appellerai
l'étoile vous promets taxé comme ça qui
va l'appeler mais je pense que si on
découvrait les toiles en même temps il y
aurait des similitudes
est ce que tu peux nous dire très fort
on entendre dans cette caméra comment
t'appellerai ton étoile style et stylé
et qu'elle nombreux tulle et donnerait
996 hockey est ce que tu peux te
retourner jupe un style et je suis pas
996 mais je suis au stylo et à 585 cas
c'est pas exactement c'était combien tu
m'as dit 986 sait pas exactement 996
mais est ce que tu es bluffer ou pas ah
quand même
je sais pas vous mais moi non plus
c'était c'était plutôt culotté je
t'avoue de faire ça comme quoi vous
voyez ça ne réussit pas à chaque fois et
je vous le prouve aujourd'hui mais
franchement j'étais pas très loin je
suis content de moi c'est bien dans
quelques semaines jean retrait voir la
vidéo que toi tu as réalisé les amoureux
ça marche
ok demain on tourne donc on va rentrer
se coucher ce soir c'est sa posture du
temps elle demain alors qu'on assure
merci à vous d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
6e tour vous a plu vous pouvez nous le
dire dans le commentaire vous pouvez
aussi me laissait un petit ours en l'air
ça rame invasion des biens et des rendez
vous demain 17h pour le prochain mortal
blog ciao